hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast 3d spheroid cell models
for drug resistance Cancer Research
presented by dr. Clarissa Willers
postdoctoral research fellow Pharma sin'
center of excellence for pharmaceutical
sciences Northwest University purchased
through South Africa I'm Alexis crowds
of laberd's and I'll be our moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is brought to you by lab
routes and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information on our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher comm
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button lens
there's many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credit please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. Clarissa Willis
dr. Clarissa Willers is a postdoctoral
research fellow at Pharma sin' Center of
Excellence for pharmaceutical sciences
at the Northwest University in South
Africa she obtained her PhD in
environmental sciences in 2016 with her
main focus on soil microbiology dr.
Willis is a part of a research team that
develops and uses cell culture models
for pharmaceutical applications she is
involved in focusing on the
bioavailability and permeability of
drugs across the membranes the overall
cytotoxicity of drugs and potential
herb-drug interactions occurring when
prescribed Western drugs are used in
conjunction with traditional plant
medicines
moreover traditional plant extracts with
possible anti cancers and wound healing
effects also form part of her research
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Willis you may
now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction hi I am
dr. Clarence Avinash and I'm honored to
be part of the GDL cell culture year's
campaign driven by Thermo Fisher
Scientific I would like to thank Chelsea
Niko and Kristy for all their
arrangements to make this webinar a
success I am a postdoctoral researcher
at the cottage Sturm campus of the
Northwest University in South Africa at
the center of excellence for
pharmaceutical sciences our cell culture
research focuses on developing novel
mammalian cell culture models for
applications in drug research mainly
traditional african medicine and the
possible interactions with conventional
medicine side by side with our host dr.
krishna health and proxy are common
my colleague dr. carla me Colette and I
of currently establishing
three-dimensional cell culture models
for multi drug-resistant cancer research
traditional 2-dimensional in vitro cell
culture models are frequently used for
anti-cancer drug research seeing of such
courses or easy to maintain and monitor
without the ethical restrictions
associated with animal studies
nevertheless numerous inconsistencies
occur between 2d findings in comparison
to in detail and clinical trial
discrepancies such as irregular cell
morphology not similar to the original
tumors issues as well as the inability
among cells to communicate and the
failure to facilitate essential
metabolic function have been reported
for cells cultured in 2d conditions
these inconsistencies may be related to
the fact that cancer cell culturing to D
allocate more of their resources into
continuous cell proliferation than into
important functional pathways also to D
cell cultures require artificial
attachment surfaces for propagation and
constant sub culturing for adequate
nutrients and growth space that leads to
concerns regarding the reliability and
credibility of to D in vitro models as
accurate screening to representative of
in diesel cancer tissue
conversely cancer cells cultured a three
dimensional thyroid cultures have been
found to more closely mimic the complex
micro environments of individuals these
3d salfi really develop intricate
extracellular matrices and can execute
intercellular communication which
enables physiological changes making
them more similar to the cancerous
tissues of Oregon using the 3d thyroid
base model the cells are no longer in an
unrestrained exponential growth phase
with proliferation is the main focus but
the 3d steroids are allowed to reach the
space of dynamic equilibrium with the
optimization of physiological processes
cellular structures and organization and
other in beaver like functionalities
occur there for 3d thyroid cultures may
be the missing link to overcome the in
vitro - in vivo data inconsistencies
prevalence in cancer research
variety of systems are available to
culture 3d spheroid models such as the
forced slicing method hanging drop
method microfluidic platform and
scaffold and matrix based approaches
each of these systems has their own
advantages and limitations and no single
method is inferior to the other it all
the things on your specific research
question here at the center of
excellence for pharmaceutical sciences
we culture our 3d spheroid cell models
in climates that by rotating bioreactors
on a cell vivo bomb system but the
kernel callers describe this system
comprehensively in a raven or of the
24th of May which is still available on
demand at lab route basically each cell
with a bump system consists of a driving
unit wireless communication and an
environmental control
the cell vivo rotating bioreactors are
ready to use with the cell chamber with
two openings for quick sampling and
medium replacements as well as a water
chamber with a week and 0.2 micron
membrane for optimum gas exchange and
humidity we use Agrawal T's to generate
our series before we transfer them to
the rotating bioreactors these Agra
wells
allow our stupid reproduce approximately
800 to 1200 spheroid
sir well depending on the number of
markers
so now I'm going to share you a video of
how a rotating bioreactor looks with
thyroid
you
furthermore these ferrets are uniform in
size and can be generated within 24
hours depending on the salon ferrets
culture in this manner usually reach
their metabolic equilibrium of the 18 to
21 days and can remain stable for a
further 21 days there for longer drug
exposures can be investigated than
traditional to the experiments ever
mentioned earlier we are currently
establishing three-dimensional cell
culture models for multidrug-resistant
Cancer Research our main goal is to
develop a research platform for
multidrug-resistant small cell lung
cancer seeing as approximately one out
of six deaths worldwide or associated
with cancer it remains a devastating and
serious health concern globally it has
been reported that in 2015 eight point
eight million cancer deaths were
documented worldwide which substantiates
the need for breakthroughs in cancer
drug research to overcome the continuous
fight against cancer small cell lung
cancer with our treatment is the most
aggressive of all the pulmonary tumors
with a survival period of only two to
four months
it is highly metastatic and even those
small cell lung cancer tumors shows in
captivity to chemotherapy and radiation
the occurrence of drug resistance and
disease relapse is very common
one of the mechanisms by which cancer
cells acquire drug resistance is the
active influx of chemotherapeutic drugs
out of the cell to reduce the drug
concentration within the cancer cell
these electrons forces of the ADC family
including PGP and MOV one of
predominantly ever expressed in various
drug resistant cancers
we are using three human small cell lung
cancer cell line of which one is Emmer
sensitive one is multidrug-resistant
through overexpression of the MRC one e
flux transporter and the last one is
also multi drug-resistant through our
expression of PGP
each of these cell lines were cultured
using Agrawal and transfer to rotating
bioreactors with a speed have adjusted
according to the spheroid size it is
important to modify your culturing
requirements to fit each cell lines
needs for example the MRP one Express
epsilon formed perfectly round compact
fairway when we seeded 1000 South per
micro well of an Agrawal 400 followed by
an incubation period of 24 hours the
pgpa Express epsilon also found steroids
although not so flawless as the first
one using the same heating concentration
in an Agrawal 400 place however the
incubation period had to be prolonged to
48 hours the chemo tentative line is so
giving us a bit of a problem as they
think you clump as soon as I transferred
to the Bari access but we are busy
preaching other method modifications at
the moment
after method optimization each thyroid
model is comprehensively characterized
to obtain a baseline of the specific
models growth properties and
functionality this approach will clarify
when the model reaches its dynamic
equilibrium space indicating from the
experimental window consults firstly we
characterized our series based on size
and protein content by taking daily
photomicrographs of the series and
measuring the planer shadow surface area
of the spirits with image day software
the 5 is the sermon the Bradford assay
is used for protein determination of
each steroids this surface area can be
directly correlated to the protein
content of the thyroid and can be used
to calculate the dosage of drugs to be
pasted in milligrams per kilogram
this is translatable to all vivo or
clinical trials in which chemotherapy is
also administered in milligrams per
kilogram dosages
taken place we characterize the spheroid
based on the daily cell viability by
determining the intracellular ATP and
extracellular
adenylate kinase level a broad overview
is obtained of the viability of the
model over time now specifically for our
three small cell lung cancer cell line
it is necessary to confirm the influx
transporter expression of each there for
gene expression using specific primers
is done to ensure that PGP and MOV one
are hyper expressed in the particular
line as indicated by the supplier
guideline other essays and imaging
techniques can also be done on the
spheroid such as proteomics is the
chemistry and transmission electron
microscopy
now that we have established 3d Pharos
models it is starting to validate them
to ensure that they adhere to our
prescription absolutely akima sensitive
model secondly a multidrug-resistant
model overexpressing
mr v1 and thirdly a multidrug-resistant
model overexpression DGP in an attempt
to validate these early models as a
platform if small cell lung cancer
research the accuracy of these 3d
spheroids analogs for in vivo clinical
drops or confirms the favored models
should be validated with well-known
standard anti-cancer drugs for which a
vast number of published data are
available our free thyroid models are
treated according to available clinical
in liver trial dosages with standard
anti-cancer drugs for 21 days of the
reaching dynamic equilibrium
these drugs are specifically chosen for
their affinity for our desired 'flag
transporters drug one is not a substrate
of particularly PGP or MOV one drug to
is a substrate for the MOV one influx
transporter and drugs three is a
substrate for the BTB transporter for
investigating the cell viability protein
content gene expression and proteomic
data the efficacy of these drugs against
the three small cell lung cancer thyroid
models are evaluated
therefore to confirm the susceptibility
of the chemo sensitive model towards the
drug the same dosage should be compared
between the chemo sensitive and
multidrug-resistant model
from our 2d investigation as seen in the
table the resistance index of the
multidrug-resistant model was very high
relative to the chemosynthesis model
moreover to confirm the multi-drug
resistance mechanism of the model alone
and a high dosage should be complete
within each cell line overall the MOC 1
hyper expressive model showed a high
tumorigenesis e towards drugs - given
that it is resistant to drug - whereas
the PGP hyper expressive model what
highlights emerging when treated with
drugs 3 seen as drug 3 is a PCP
substrates these obtained results should
however so be investigated in our 3d
favorite
we are investigating several other
application service validated
small-scale long time for platforms the
rich plant biodiversity of Africa in the
source of medicinal plant for centuries
with many success stories of patients
that secured a new treatment source from
indigenous plants
traditional herbal medicine relies on
knowledge handed down from generation to
generation term can refer among others
through the use of remedies based on
thorns to diagnose treat or cure
conditions herbal medicines form a key
component of African traditional
medicinal practices and in some regions
especially rural areas traditional
medicines may be the main or even the
only source of health care available it
is also highly popular because of
accessibility affordability and cultural
acceptability some active constituents
in herbal medicine can modulate reflux
transporter expression and activity
potentially decreasing the multi-drug
resistance via a flock for example
curcumin derived from the dried reserves
of Curcuma longa or turmeric has been
shown to inhibit PGP function and
expression in cancer cells reversing
MOCA drug resistance is fake
modification of a flux transporter
expression and activity by medicinal
flown can potentially be used for the
management of multi-drug resistance in
cancer cells by reducing key flux of
anti-cancer drugs cancer patients often
use herbal preparation and traditional
medicine concomitantly worse they
prescribed anti cancer drug the belief
exists the traditional medicine of
natural origin only holds advantages for
users without any adverse or toxic
effects however herbal medicine may have
pharmacokinetic interactions with
conventional drugs altering the
bioavailability and effectiveness
therefore the identification of
potential
herb-drug interactions is necessary for
the well-being of patients suffering
from cancer here is a list of
publications in which we have studied
herb-drug interactions screening for the
anti-cancer efficacy of newly developed
drugs and the combination with
traditionally used medicinal plants
using 3d cancer cell thyroid my access
in identifying potential new therapies
while reducing unnecessary animal safety
in conclusion 3d thyroid models are
becoming the gold standard in
preclinical cancer drug screens however
it is important to keep in mind that 3d
sphero's are not supposed to replace in
vivo or clinical trials on the contrary
it should rather refine the choice of
preferred drugs for a reduced number of
further envy based studies but with 3d
the possibilities are endless
I would just like to send the following
entities for funding the National
Research Foundation of South Africa and
the South African Medical Research
Council then office our result for the
opportunity to use their excellent
system it contributes surely this trace
3/3 for more information on the Salva
verbum system and Agrawal please see the
attached list
thank you now you can join us for a last
question and answers
Thank You dr. Willis for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left your screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started
our first question is how does the MDR 1
and PGP results in fear of scheming
result in steroids compared to those and
2d cultures
um well that question I can actually not
answer completely as our results are
still not published so you're wasting
the process of taking and weekly don't
fumble for gene expression so yeah but
we would and suggest that the gene
expression would be much more unstable
that in the thyroids then into the
culture
and our next question how are the ICI
50s measured can these vary based on
endpoint example cell death spheroid
size and/or oversight tock cytotoxicity
verse inhibition of growth
okay and the
see fifties and we use I see fifties for
the 2d data that I shown in the table we
measured this with an ATP and are gonna
let a adenine triphosphate a face as
well as adenylate kinase level and and
then it's an endpoint after 96 hours
and give me just understand it and yeah
I don't know that I answer the question
completely
yeah basically sell this and the
reduction of the file variability
and dr. Willis here is going to be our
next question in a simple rotation
method in order to form steroids you use
24 Wells plates or six wells and in each
one you have to get one spheroid so is
it the same
um
okay let me just understand the question
so you want to know if we use a twin for
wild flight we use one one and Wow can
make up to 1000 series that means that
were micro well in each well and you it
stays 1000 cells in each micro well that
gives you one spheroid and so yeah it
depends that Agrawal we buy or a 24 well
plate but you can you can get around
about 1000 steroids out of one well yeah
doctor
we're getting some so many good
questions so here's our next one how can
3d spheroid cells a process for gene
expression
and I don't understand the question it's
rubbish a return expression you yes
it is question over thrown over time
okay you would um sample the ferret out
of the bioreactor then and because our
sampling is done before we can do the
gene expression we would store them in
RNA later and then and after when you
want to use them you just wash their RNA
later out according to the manufacture
guidelines and then you continue with
your RNA extraction and your your am
normal and real-time PCR your resistant
transcription processes after such a
long culturing period how big is your
spheroids and how deep with the
nutrients or cancer drugs have
penetrated through the spheroid
and well our favorites cultured in the
finest fact-based
rotating by reactive can reach up to
size of one millimeter in diameter
although this can vary depending on the
type of fan line you use although we
have not tasted our came to drag this
tribution whisking our steroids eh I
believe that if you use label drugs you
will be able to investigate the drug
penetration within the steroids and
given the fact that this culturing
system is an irrigated system there is
continuous flow of the media and
nutrients around the spheroid and this
results in a smaller diffusion depletion
zone around your theory and in
comparison to other static or passive
systems but there are previous studies
that have shown that steroids
coltd in rotating bio reactors have
sufficient oxygen diffusion throughout
the spheroid
even and do the call
and it looks like our next question is
going to be shouldn't protein content
scale with the volume and not the
surface area of the steroid I wouldn't
expect a linear relationship in this
case
well our collaborate collaborators in
Denmark and they did a lot of studies
and they found they actually found a
linear correlation between the steroid
and surface area the shadow area that
you measure as well as the protein
content and yeah but but if you want to
do if you want to use their volume it
would be a destructive method and you
would have to break up your steroid so
yeah we yeah we don't do that so you can
just and make a lookup table and for
each cell type during your
characterization
now dr. Willers this is a two-part
question what main challenges of 3d
culture are there any particular safety
concerns
okay yeah it's not it's an easy method
but if you don't have any sour
experience and I would rather say that
you first get proper training on two DS
and then you can move to your 3d and
processes my challenge for us in South
Africa it is expensive and the whole bum
system as well as the
bioreactors are very expensive and we
have to import them into the country
that is a big challenge for us um yeah
thing the ugly walls are also expensive
and and when the favourites are very
small they require a daily checkup
you're just to adjust the speed and
stuff and safety concerns well it's it's
itself so we wear our PPE our personal
protective equipment and our salons that
we use our biosafety level work so
you're that's there yeah safety concerns
regarding regarding 3d our next question
it is also a two-part question do you
think this technique is cost-effective
or is it more expensive than a mice
model
and okay well I would say it is much
cheaper than a mouse model and we get a
lot of data out of our and steroids
during the 42 day period and you can
sample more frequently and this is where
mice the sampling and periods are
limited due to the ethical constraints
and
the mice models if you use vinegar offs
they take a long period to form a proper
cancer or a tumor and which you can
measure the volume of it takes at least
let's say eight months for a proper team
across two to four yeah so yeah my
money's on the bleeding
we're getting so many good questions
from our audience so let's continue with
with these what kind of matrix or
hydrogels
do you use to grow spheroids
and well for our three lines that we
that I discussed on the presentation is
no matrix or hydrogel to support the
self and the moment you put them in the
agrawal they think to cluster and form a
tight links between each other
so you're they don't have any and
supporting and matrix or scaffold or
something and but with other our we have
another line and that my colleague dr.
Carol inequalities working on she users
and might read a Maitre gel like sodium
out tonight
and I got ill so I hope that answered
the question
most of our next one how will you
measure the stability of your drug
resistance in your spheroid models for
the duration of your experiments
and as I've already mentioned during
characterization there's a we we do
continuous sampling for the gene
expression and to determine if there's
any possible changes in our gene
expression profile now during the
experiments we will also determine the
gene expression weekly and then you can
evaluate the changes induced by your
specific drug treatment
and it looks like our next question is
going to be is the medium you use for 2d
culture the same as you use for 3d
culturing
and you're definitely and but we have
found that adding vitamin C ascorbic
acid to the media in a specific
concentration also helps the cells to
form
let's fight and save Lloyd yeah but the
medium is exactly the same so it looks
like we have about five more minutes to
answer any questions so let's continue
let's go to our next one can we detect
metabolic reprogramming of tumor cells
in steroids
and yes you can and you can do metabolic
reprogramming by using proteomics and
where you take out your thyroid and you
yeah it's like basically and it's
proteomics so um you know you sample
your thyroid it's a bit disruptive
technique but it is possible you're you
can do metabolic profiling and you can
actually look at some of our
collaborators this articles
it's the rinsky and say 2018 it is on my
list of references
so our next
question would it be possible to culture
primary cells directly derived from a
cancer patient as a as a sea road for
further personalized medicine
application
and yes it is possible in fact and
primary cultures growing 2d have a very
limited experimental window as I think -
they tend to D differentiate and lose
several key characteristics within let's
say 72 hours so therefore by culturing
them in 3d rotating bioreactors they can
retain the morphology their viability
and organ specific function for at least
four weeks and therefore they more
closely resemble and the in vivo tissues
now a patient's primary tumor cells can
be used to generate a number of 3d
steroids and these steroids can then be
studied concurrently or ahead of the
actual and patient treatment program
this approach can help guide the
therapeutic management of your clinical
trial and introduce key features
necessary for the development of
personalized medicine
it looks like we have another two-part
question here do you consider using
serum in this model and which serum do
you consider in the media
and yes we use and we use FPS in our
media and it's exactly the same and
percentage as what you would use in 2d
and I don't want to say our brand name
but your we more use normal fetal bovine
serum that a full foul work its
unsterile halted gamma-irradiated yeah
alright and it looks like we have time
for one more question if you want to can
you take your spheroid out of the well
for metabolic profiling study
out of the well the favors are in a
bioreactor so um they are not in a while
they are prepared in the world but then
after incubation period in the world you
transfer them into your bio reactors so
from the bioreactor you do your daily
something yeah and I don't know I will
kill one two samples from the well
well we would like to thank you again
dr. Willis do you have any final
comments for our audience
oh wow nothing from my side but thank
you so much for the opportunity and if
you have any further questions please
follow us on LinkedIn and ResearchGate
and Instagram please look at our list of
references yeah thank you so much
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of the registration we would like to
thank dr. Williams for her time today
and her important research we would also
like to take laberd and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through February of 2019 labret will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye